-Last "Corrections" of 2021.
Welcome, everybody.
So excited to jump
right into it.
I referred to Philadelphia
Cream Cheese as "Philly's Best."
Philly's Best
is a cheesesteak restaurant,
and I realized my error
when someone from Philadelphia
threw a battery at me.
Also known as a
Philadelphia How Do You Do?
We talked about the anime
"Sailor Moon"
as if it was a current show.
We were aware that we were
probably wrong about that,
and someone did write and say
the final episode
of "Sailor Moon"
was February 8th, 1997.
And I would just say to
that person, the next time
you give that information
to someone, just the year.
You know, based on
their reaction,
I think that'll let you know
if they want the month and day.
Oh, so this was interesting.
So we did a "Day Drinking"
with Will Forte.
I highly recommend you watch it.
It was great.
And we showed Edvard Munch
"The Scream,"
and Will was doing voices
of the paintings
and he, as you would expect,
screamed, and someone said,
"You know, the person in this
painting is not screaming.
They're reacting to a scream,"
which I didn't know,
and I guess Edvard Munch
only saw --
I mean, imagine
if you were there
and you missed the screen.
You know, you hear a scream
and then you run over
and you're like,
"Could you do it again?
I'd love to paint it."
"No, no.
I'm not going to do it again."
"I was like, yeah,
but I'm just --
I'm a painter and I feel like
that's what people
are going to want to see."
"You could paint
someone reacting to it."
But this is also fascinating,
because we also showed
the "Mona Lisa."
And I was told this
is actually a woman
looking at a woman
named Mona Lisa.
[ Laughter ]
And according to Michelangelo,
what he wanted to do
was paint a woman
who was friends with
a woman named Mona Lisa,
and Mona Lisa's always late.
And so this woman
is always waiting for her.
And then, one day --
And you know, when you have
a friend who's always late
and you're just waiting,
and you know they're gonna be
full of excuses.
And so Mona Lisa
basically sees her
and does that like --
you know, the like --
Does that, and then that
thing where you like,
speed up, jog a little bit,
like, "Oh, I'm going to
try to close the gap
of how late I am,"
and then slipped
and just ate it.
So that's the little smile.
It's like if
your friend was super late
and then, like,
fell really hard.
This woman's name is
Debbie Schwartz.
[ Laughter ]
I often say,
when I learn something, I say,
"Oh, this is interesting,"
and someone told me,
"You shouldn't say that,
because it's not conclusive.
You should say,
'I find this interesting.'"
But problem with that is,
I don't.
[ Laughter ]
I mispronounced
"target audience"
and said "target ardience."
But that is on purpose.
Carol Burnett would
always do this to
signal to her grandmother.
So every now and then,
I will say a word
pirate-style
for the Sea Captain.
Now I will say,
with "target audience,"
I just should have said
"tarrrget audience."
I feel like to go
"target arrdience"
was a bit of --
it was a stretch.
What did I get wrong here?
Okay. I said --
We made a joke about Don Jr.
being in
"The Fellowship of the Rings."
My bad.
It's "Lord of the Rings:
Fellowship of the Ring,"
which I can't believe I forgot,
because it just
rolls off the tongue.
We're going to start
calling this
"Late Night with Seth Meyers:
A Late Night Show."
[ Laughter ]
I talked about
my beautiful baby girl,
and I have forgotten to mention
that her middle name is Ruth,
after my wife's grandmother,
and her first name is Adelaide.
And like four of you,
after I said her name
was Adelaide Ruth Meyers, said,
"Oh, so her initials are ARM?"
Like it was a burn.
[ Laughter ]
Like she's going
to be in school one day
and a mean kid's going to go,
"What's up, ARM?"
"What?
Sorry, what did you say?"
"ARM.
That's your name, isn't it?
Addie Ruth Meyers, ARM?"
"Uh, yeah, I guess.
I'm sorry,
what's your point?"
"I thought you'd be
with Leslie...
Garrison."
"What are you talking about?"
"Leslie Erica Garrison. LEG?
I thought you guys
would be hanging out.
Bye."
We made a Clippy joke and said
this was a joke from 1995.
Clippy was actually
introduced in 1997.
To soften the blow after
"Sailor Moon" had been canceled.
We mentioned "House,"
and you know, again --
we know at this point,
people who watch the show
we're basically watching it
for the impressions.
And we mentioned
Hugh Laurie's House,
and people were so bummed
I didn't do it.
It's tricky.
It's tricky to do
British people who do --
because I can do Hugh Laurie,
but then you've got to do...
You can't just do the voice
he does as House.
You've got to go in his mind
as a British person
and switch it over.
[ As House ]
I think it's this.
So, Hugh Grant,
because Hugh Grant is like --
[ Mumbling as Hugh Grant ]
It's exhausting,
but this would be
Hugh Grant as an American.
Alright, so remember,
here's British.
It's like -- [ Mumbling ]
[ In American accent ]
"Welcome to Late Night."
[ Laughter ]
I'm so bummed, because --
Alright, so Matthew McConaughey
was on the show,
and I'm just bummed because,
you know,
it's incumbent upon me
as a talk show host
to know I have a funny thing
to tell a guest,
and the funny thing I would have
told Matthew McConaughey
is the other day, my son Axel,
we're getting him dressed
for school,
and all of a sudden
I look at him and I realize,
"Oh, I know exactly
who you look like.
You look like a character
in a movie,
and that movie
is 'Dazed and Confused,'
and Axel,
you look like Wooderson."
[ Laughter ]
And if Peter Billingsley
is ever on the show,
I'm going to tell him
my son looks like
Ralphie from
"A Christmas Story."
We kind of talked about
how this might be like a
"hey, it's the end of the year"
"Corrections" spectacular,
but I got to be honest,
it was it was too much work.
I do this alone and I have
too much going on.
It was too much work.
I also came up
with the idea too late.
But now the reality is,
I think March 1st
is the year anniversary
of "Corrections,"
so basically, this is
a pre-spectacular.
We're just going
to move the date,
and I think now
we'll get a team, obviously.
I think NBC will
obviously pay for a team.
But it was fun
and I want to thank,
because I asked you to send in
your favorite things
that were #BestOf,
and these are my favorite.
Someone said, "My favorite
correction was October 25th,
when Seth said --"
Alright, so here's what I said.
I made a mistake
doing a mimed phone call,
and I said
that really bums me out,
because I feel like as far
as phone call comedy,
one-sided phone call comedy,
I am the new Bob Newhart,
the Bob New-hart,
if you will.
And this person's favorite
moment was when I made that joke
and a guy, audibly irritated,
said, "Oh, my God."
Let's see if you can hear it.
When it comes to doing
one-sided phone call comedy,
I am the new Bob Newhart,
The Bob New-hart, if you will.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-Baze.
Let's isolate it.
-Oh, my God.
-That you, Baze?
I need your support.
Because Baze comes up with
terrible jokes all the time.
[ Laughter ]
All the time,
and I don't tell him,
to save him the embarrassment.
Like, for example,
another correction I got
is instead of
"consolation prize,"
I accidentally said
"constellation prize,"
and Baze said,
"You should go out and say,
'It's okay when you say
consolation prize,
because you're a star.'"
[ Laughter ]
Some of the things
people liked, and again,
when we get to the Spectacular,
March 1st,
obviously,
we'll tick all these boxes.
Everybody like the Pixar movie
that we talked about.
If you guys don't remember,
the Pixar movie
is about chickens
that go undercover in Germany
during World War II
as eggs and then hatched
to help other farm animals,
resistance farm animals, escape.
Pixar, very excited, they
gave us a new title for it --
"Ca-Ca-Call of Duty."
People love
the graphics department.
They love that we have
a graphics team
that makes mistakes and loves
when they get punished
for those mistakes,
because they all have
a humiliation fetish.
And I actually went down
and I was like,
"Well, congratulations, you
made Best of Corrections,
and they were so bummed.
I was like, "What's wrong?"
They were like, "Well,
isn't there a Worst Of?"
I was like,
"Fine, you're Worst Of."
And they were like, "Oh, no."
And the graphics department,
every single week,
we do a different mug
and they find out
in the morning.
I'm like, "Hey, can you
make something for me?"
And there's this one.
I do think that
we've joked about the fact
that there's
no "Correction" merch.
I feel like this -- I feel like
that's the mug, right?
So I set up a meeting with NBC
to go in and basically,
you know,
raise some hell and be like,
"Hey, it's time
for 'Corrections' merch."
At which point, I'm assuming
they're going to do that thing
where they're like,
"Yeah, absolutely,"
to cover for the fact they don't
know what I'm talking about.
"Yeah, absolutely. Yes."
But the important thing is,
when we sell these,
every dollar we raise,
which I think is really cool,
is going to go to me.
[ Laughter ]
I think we maybe
will have guests
when we do the Spectacular.
Get Patty Lyons here,
our knitting friend,
Doof Warrior.
Werner Herzog, maybe.
I mean, they could send
in video messages,
Maybe we'll find
a [bleep] sociopath
that says Lego Bricks.
We talked about this before
and people complained,
"Hey, if it's not on TV,
why are there bleeps
on the YouTube video?"
YouTube does that.
YouTube bleeps it.
That's not our fault.
More troubling to me,
Someone pointed out,
"You know, sometimes YouTube,
the closed captioning,"
which is very valuable
and it means the world to us
that they closed caption it --
But sometimes
they put (Laughter).
Sometimes they put
(Light laughter)."
[ Laughter ]
That's not for you to decide.
"Cicada, Cicada."
I mean, that's really the goal.
I think March 1st might be
too soon for "Cicada, Cicada."
Got to write some songs
for "Cicada, Cicada."
I mean, with the cast
locked down.
They've all committed
for the next year.
But, you know, I want to
write a song about,
I think a beautiful song
would be the cicada finding out
that they only have, like,
four weeks to live.
Like, I think a beautiful song
for Ms. Christine Baranski
would be like, how four weeks
in New York City
is a lifetime anywhere else.
I think that's really beautiful.
And then I have a scene
where the cockroach --
and this is gonna be
a very topical show.
It's going to be very tied into
the world we're living in now.
You know, the Mets-loving
cockroach will come in
and there will be a scene
that starts
where he's like, "Bad news.
I just came back
from the doctor and...
and I tested positive."
And they'll say,
"Oh, no. For coronavirus?"
And he'll say, "No.
For the Mets!
♪ The doc says it's as bad
as it gets ♪
♪ Fever, bad cough,
and the sweats ♪
♪ I said, Is there a cure? ♪
♪ He said, "Sure. ♪
♪ I take a hammer
and I hit you on the head ♪
♪ Until you forgets ♪
I'd like to let you guys
behind the curtain
on "Corrections" a little bit,
which is --
We now have three kids, and
the 3-month-old has a cough,
and it's just terrible.
Kids getting sick is awful.
And especially, you know,
in this time we're living in.
everything, you just
worry about what it is.
And you know, for my wife,
she's got this 3-month-old
that has this cough.
And you know,
our boys, they're 3 and 5,
and no matter
how much you try to tell them,
like, it's
a really stressful morning,
they don't understand.
Like, they're loving
and they're sweet,
but they don't understand,
and they're just gonna
run around and be themselves.
So the only person in my
wife's life who lives with her,
who could understand and
behave differently is me.
And yet this morning,
while this was all happening,
I was...
writing down lyrics of things
that rhymed with the Mets.
[ Laughter ]
And like,
singing to myself, like --
♪ Bernie Goetz ♪
I feel terrible, you know.
But then she comes over
and she's like,
"What are you doing?"
And I was like,
"Well, I'm writing lyrics
for a Broadway musical."
And she was like,
"You can't do this right now."
And I was like, "Do you think
Sondheim's wife
ever said that to him?"
And she was like,
"Sondheim never had a wife."
And I said, "Exactly!"
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so like I said,
I blew it
in that I promised a Spectacular
that didn't happen.
I do want to give you
a treat, though.
One thing that people always ask
about with this show is,
"Hey, how come we never see
Mikey the Shoe?"
People want to see him,
and he doesn't want to be seen,
but it's, I don't know,
maybe consider a Christmas gift.
So anyway, for everybody at home
who's never seen him,
do please enjoy Mikey the Shoe.
-Ohhh, you don't never put
Mikey the Shoe's face on camera!
-Why?
-'Cause I got people
who are lookin' for me!
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm sorry, we have to pay
you guys overtime for that?
I'm lucky I've got
that mug money about to roll in.
See me in two weeks.
Happy holidays, everybody.